you guys ready for Valentine's Day
everybody all set what happened there
that was uh that was tragic we have not
a very romantic crowd here tonight now I
will spend it alone oh really it's
fantastic tomorrow is Valentine's Day
President Trump says he's going to have
a quiet intimate dinner with the love of
his life Donald Trump I love you here's
a fun fact about Valentine's Day an
average man spends a hundred and ninety
six dollars on Valentine's Day yeah
works out to 25 dollars for the first
present then 171 dollars for the makeup
president afterwards
Vee sorry for the beef jerky I did that
one year got my wife beef jerky beef
jerky really yeah well my first wife she
left check it out a woman who's been
married 38 years gifted her husband her
kidney for Valentine's Day right yeah
here's the sad part he didn't need one
yeah he's kept it on a yeah and she did
and she's gone anyway dad that's right
dad
why did you laugh at that part she
bagged she did not but one day